-Our first guest tonight
is an actress,
a Grammy Award-winning musician,
and a member of
the Country Music Hall of Fame.
Her new album and book,
both titled
"Not That Fancy,"
are available now.
She's also a coach
on "The Voice,"
which airs Mondays
and Tuesdays here on NBC.
Let's take a look.
-I want some tots before we go.
-Yeah, let's do it.
-I want some tots.
-I am retiring
Reba's Tot Cart.
-Reba's Team is full, y'all.
-This is my first season
on "The Voice."
I've had a blast
filling my team
and I can't believe
how quickly it passed by.
And that's what happens
when you're having fun.
I'll just be over here
with my tater tots.
-[ Laughs ]
-Y'all need me.
-Please welcome back to the show
the one, the only
Reba McIntyre, everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Welcome back, Reba.
What an honor to see you again.
-So long since I've seen you.
-Well, it was last night.
-Oh, was it? That's right.
-It was last night.
-Time flies when you're
having fun.
-We did a wonderful event at
town hall
for your book last night
right here in New York City.
And my goodness, your fans
were out in full force.
The people that love you,
they love you very much.
And I hope you felt
it last night
because that was
a special evening.
-I thought it was a lot of fun.
You did a great job.
-Thank you.
I'm very glad I did it
because now I'm going
to make you tell another story
you told last night because
it was so good.
You know, this book
is a very wonderful collection
of stories and anecdotes,
and you can tell how much
your family means to you,
generations of the McIntyres.
But you were talking
about your mama.
And I think it was a story about
your grandmother needed a drink.
Is that right?
-No, Mama.
-It was your mama. Okay.
-Yeah.
We were at her house
and all the family was there
and the grandkids and kids
and everybody
was running around.
And Mama's nerves had just
gotten about right to here.
And I looked over
at her and I said, "Mama,
you need a shot of who hit him?"
[ Laughter ]
It's either a shot of who hit
him or a shot of who done it.
-Okay.
[ Laughter ]
-And she said, "Yeah,"
She told Lou Casey,
her granddaughter,
she said, "Lou, come here."
She said, "I want you
to go in my bedroom.
Go in the bathroom,
look in the bottom
of my dirty clothes hamper
and bring me a bottle
of Crown out here."
[ Laughter ]
She said, "Got it."
And I said, "Mama,
why do you put your Crown
in the bottom
of your dirty clothes hamper?"
She said,
"Do you think my grandsons
are going to go in there
checking for Crown
in my dirty clothes?"
[ Laughter ]
-I love it.
She's one step ahead of them.
-Telling you.
-She stayed one step
ahead of them.
-Absolutely. Always.
-Well, we were talking about
"The Voice" last night as well.
I mean, obviously,
there's a great camaraderie
between you
and the other judges.
But is there one of them
you have your eye on
as the toughest competition?
-John.
-Yeah.
-John Legend. Yeah.
John's got a great knack
for picking great singers.
And when we're
with our backs
to the singers
that come on to audition,
I'm always kind of
going thataway,
looking at John, seeing if
John's going to hit his button.
Well, John's really sneaky.
He won't do anything.
He'll just be [Humming]
And go like that.
And we're all like, "Oh, man!"
-Yeah.
-But it's fun.
-You seem like
you're having a fun time.
-I really am.
-It's lovely.
You also -- I hope you had fun
writing this book
because like I said, it is
a collection of a lot of things.
It's recipes, it's self-help,
it's your own story.
And while you're writing it
and also the album as well,
this is a collection of songs
you've done before, some new,
but mostly just a reimagining
of some wonderful songs.
And both of them are a real gift
to your, you know, your fans
and people who maybe are going
to be a fan after they read it.
But of these recipes,
can you just tell us real quick,
your tater tots recipe,
because that is one that
I'm the most confident
anyone can do.
-Thank you very much.
Yes. You get in your car.
-Yep.
-And you put it in reverse.
Get out of the garage
and drive down the road
and you find your nearest Sonic.
-Yep.
-Pull in the entrance,
not the exit.
-Yep.
-And you pull in one of
them little slots and you push
that red button and you say,
"Can I have me some tater tots?"
[ Laughter and applause ]
And I hope they don't say
"We're out."
-Yeah. And you hope
you don't say they're out.
Thank you for putting put
in the go in the entrance,
not the exit, because I think
that's the one part
I always get wrong
about the recipe.
-Well, yeah.
Yeah, I've done that.
-You do have this wonderful
new restaurant
called Reba's Place in Atoka.
Am I saying that?
Atoka, Oklahoma?
-Yes.
-And that's also a music venue.
-Yeah, it's got
a little bitty stage.
-A little bitty stage.
But you were talking about
how you kind of go in there
every now and then,
and I would imagine it's called
Reba's Place, you're Reba.
You walk in,
people get excited right away.
But you were saying sometimes
they just don't even
notice it's you.
-Yeah, we did a surprise
appearance,
and Pake, my older brother,
was up playing,
and he kind of got down
and my band snuck up there,
three or four of them,
and I came through the kitchen
and hopped up on the bandstand
and started singing
"Can't Even Get the Blues"
and nobody said anything.
[ Laughter ]
I mean, they didn't even look up
from their chicken fried steak.
They were serious about it.
And all of a sudden I went
[Clears throat]
and they went, "What is that?"
And they go...
-That's pretty exciting.
-Yeah, well.
-I guess they just
couldn't believe Reba would
actually be at Reba's Place.
But there you go.
-I guess they thought it was,
you know, playing over
the speakers or something.
-It does speak
to the quality of the food.
They won't even look up
from their chicken fried steak.
-I'm going to use that.
-There you go.
-Thank you.
-You have some farmers
that are showing their love
for you
in the launch of this book
and this album.
I mean, I don't even know
how you go about this,
but I will say
it's incredibly impressive.
These are -- I guess they're
just using some real good
lawnmowers.
So there's Von Thun Farms.
-I'm asked,
"How do they do that?"
-Here's another one.
That's a very good Reba as well.
I mean...
-How about that?
-I mean, it's worth
getting a small plane
just to go up and fly
around this country
to see where your face
is turning up, right?
-Do they put a computer chip
in the tractor or something?
How do they do that?
-I think they might.
I was trying to figure it out,
but you're right.
There's probably computers.
-No idea. Yeah.
-Every time you see something,
you're like,
"How did they do that?"
The answer It's a computer.
Yeah.
-It's not just they found a guy
who really knows
what you look like
and put him behind a tractor,
and you're like, "Do your best."
-Yeah. "Go for it."
-Do you have fun
rerecording old songs?
-I do. Dave Cobb --
He and I worked on this album
to strip it down
and get just to the meat
of the song
and not a big production,
which I had done originally
for these songs.
And so it just really
brought out the --
the heart and soul of the song,
I think.
Like, for instance,
"Consider Me Gone"
is one of the songs on it.
That's Rex's favorite song.
And it just -- I like
the song more now
when I get to sing it
because it's softer.
-Well, that's really wonderful.
You know, I got to see you
do a few songs last night.
I can't wait to listen to
the whole album start to finish,
and it's such a joy
to have you here.
Thanks so much
for stopping by.
-My pleasure.
-That's Reba McIntyre,
everybody.
"Not That Fancy,"
the book and the album
are on sale now,
and "The Voice" airs Mondays
and Tuesdays
right here on NBC. We'll be
right back with Werner Herzog.